Ford Motor Company today is expected to
announce a new CEO the automaker is
reportedly removing chief executive Mark
fields in a management shakeup he will
apparently be replaced by Jim Hackett
who oversees Ford's mobility unit
Fields has led Ford for nearly three
years his reported firing comes amid
struggling sales and concern about plans
for the high-tech cars of the future we
reached out to Ford but the automaker
said it would not comment on the report
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here Jill good morning
good morning big move why the shake-up
well you look at the stock price first
indicator down about 40 percent since
fields has taken over nearly three years
ago but then look at some other metrics
profitability down sales sales this year
down almost by 25 percent and I think
the biggest issue here is if your core
business is down and you're not
innovating quickly enough you are going
to be punished by not just the
shareholders but also the board was he
quickly moving in terms of the places
that Tesla is no and I think that's a
big issue around innovation because we
see not just lagging say Tesla which is
already in the market but let's just
look at Google or even GM it looked like
Ford was going to be able to produce an
electric car by 2021 my gosh that's a
long time from now and you see that not
just in the internally but externally a
lot of the shareholders saying what's
going on we need more innovation quicker
I remember mark fields was sitting in
the very seat where you are sitting when
he was here what can you tell us about
the new guy who's in line to replace him
well again he came in from a totally
different business from Steelcase
furniture he's going to be focusing on
this mobility venture now I just want to
point out you know look we're talking
about for it as if it's some stumbling
company for it still sells a lot of cars
it is profitable and if you look at
Tesla versus for it Tesla sold 76,000
cars last year that's it Ford sold 6.7
million it's just not the right kind of
cars but still making a profit
absolutely profitable thank you Jim
thank you Joe